[Music]
won't be assigns badass alright you
don't have a computer alright but you
know that gravity drops off as the
distance squared okay but you don't have
a computer to calculate the force of
gravity for all these stars at all times
Eric Homburg when was this in 1440 a of
the 40's named Eric Homburg a colleague
a virgin another generation a giant and
wanted to simulate colliding galaxies
okay and he does know computers so he
took light bulbs and light meters and
measured the intensity of the light
because light drops off as the distance
squared right and he used light as a
proxy for gravity and he had a
mechanical pad a table with like pegs in
it and he would see it he would see
which way the light was right and he'd
move his light bulbs according to what
the light meters told him he should do
and he watched the evolution of a
colliding sister read the piece when you
read the paper you know dating back to
the 1940s it is just you just amazed at
how creative and how completely out of
the box he was thinking absolutely
remarkable
Mike yeah he was using pen and paper
right and light meters to do what couple
moderate computers do today but what is
what is just so like give me the first
bump for Erich Hoeber